good evening
from the university of utah in salt lake
city welcome to the first
and only vice presidential debate of
2020
sponsored by the nonpartisan commission
on presidential debates
i'm susan page of usa today it is my
honor
to moderate this debate an important
part of our democracy
in kingsbury hall tonight we have a
small and socially distant audience
and we've taken extra precautions during
this pandemic
among other things everyone in the
audience is required to wear a face mask
and the candidates will be seated 12
feet apart
the audience is enthusiastic about their
candidates but they've agreed to express
that enthusiasm
only twice at the end of the debate and
now
when i introduce the candidates please
welcome
california senator kamala harris and
vice president mike pence
thank you
senator harris and vice president pence
thank you for being here
we're meeting as president trump and the
first lady continue to undergo treatment
in washington
after testing positive for covid19 we
send our thoughts and prayers to them
for their rapid and complete recovery
and for the recovery of everyone
afflicted by the coronavirus
the two campaigns in the commission on
presidential debates have agreed to the
ground rules for tonight
i'm here to enforce them on behalf of
the millions of americans who are
watching
one note no one in either campaign or at
the commission
or anywhere else has been told in
advance what topics i'll raise
or what questions i'll ask this 90
minute debate will be divided into nine
segments of about 10 minutes each i'll
begin a segment by posing a question
to each of you sometimes the same
question sometimes a different question
on the same topic you will then have two
minutes to answer
without interruption by me or the other
candidate
then we'll take six minutes or so to
discuss the issue
at that point although there will always
be more to say
we'll move on to the next topic we want
a debate that is lively but americans
also deserve a discussion that is civil
these are tumultuous times but we can
and will
have a respectful exchange about the big
issues
facing our nation let's begin with the
ongoing pandemic
that has cost our country so much
senator harris the coronavirus is not
under control
over the past week johns hopkins reports
that
39 states have had more coveted cases
over the past seven days
than in the week before nine states have
set new records even if a vaccine is
released soon
the next administration will face hard
choices
what would a biden administration do in
january and february
that a trump administration wouldn't do
would you impose
new lockdowns for businesses in schools
and hot spots
a federal mandate to wear masks you have
two minutes to respond without
interruption
thank you susan well the
american people have witnessed what is
the greatest failure
of any presidential administration in
the history of our country
and here are the facts 210
000 dead people in our country in just
the last several months
over seven million people who have
contracted this disease
one in five businesses closed
we're looking at frontline workers who
have been treated
like sacrificial workers we are looking
at
over 30 million people
who in the last several months had to
file for unemployment
and here's the thing on january 28th
the vice president and the president
were informed about the nature of this
pandemic they were informed that it's
lethal
in consequence that it is airborne
that it will affect young people and
that
it would be contracted because it is
airborne
and they knew what was happening and
they didn't tell
you can you imagine if you knew on
january 28th
as opposed to march 13th what they knew
what you might have done to prepare
they knew and they covered it up the
president said it was a hoax
they minimized the seriousness of it the
president said
you're on one side of his ledger if you
wear a mask you're on the other side of
his ledger
if you don't and in spite of all of that
today they still don't have a plan
they still don't have a plan well joe
biden does and our plan is about
what we need to do around a national
strategy for contact
tracing for testing for administration
of the vaccine
and making sure that it will be free for
all
that is the plan that joe biden has and
that i have
knowing that we have to get a hold of
what has been going on
and we need to save our country and joe
biden is the best leader to do that and
frankly this administration has
forfeited
thank you their right to re-election
based on this thank you senator harris
vice president pence more than 210 000
americans have died of covet 19
since february the u.s death toll as a
percentage of our population
is higher than that of almost every
other wealthy nation
on earth for instance our death rate is
two and a half times that of canada next
door
you head the administration's
coronavirus task force
why is the u.s death toll as a
percentage of our population
higher than that of almost every other
wealthy country
and you have two minutes to respond
without interruption susan thank you
and i want to thank the commission and
the university of utah for
hosting this event and uh senator harris
it's privileged to be on the stage with
you
and our nation has gone through a very
challenging time this year
but i want the american people to know
that from the very
first day president donald trump has put
the health of america first
before there were more than five cases
in the united states
all people who had returned from china
president donald trump did what no other
american president had ever done
and that was he suspended all travel
from china the second largest economy
in the world now senator
joe biden biden opposed that decision
he said it was xenophobic and hysterical
but i can tell you having led the white
house coronavirus task force that that
decision alone by president trump
bought us invaluable time to stand up
the greatest national mobilization
since world war ii and i believe it
saved hundreds of
thousands of american lives because with
that time we were able to reinvent
testing more than 115 million tests had
been done to date
we were able to see to the delivery of
billions of supplies so our doctors and
nurses had the resources support they
needed
and we began really before the month of
february was art to develop a vaccine
and to develop medicines and
therapeutics had been saving lives all
along the way
and under president trump's leadership
operation warp speed we believe we'll
have
literally tens of millions of doses of a
vaccine before the end of this year
the reality is when you look at the
biden plan it reads an awful lot
like what president trump and i and our
task force have been doing every step
of the way and quite frankly
when i look at their plan that talks
about advancing testing
creating new ppe developing a vaccine
it looks a little bit like plagiarism
which is something joe biden knows a
little bit about
and i think the american people know
that this is a president who has put the
health of america
first and the american people i believe
with my heart
can be proud of the sacrifices they have
made
it's safe thank you american lives
senator harris
would you like to respond absolutely
whatever the vice president is claiming
the administration has done
clearly it hasn't worked when you're
looking at over 210
000 dead bodies in our country american
lives
that have been lost families that are
grieving that loss
and you know the vice president is the
head of the task force
and knew on january 28th how serious
this was and then
thanks to bob woodward we learned
that they knew about it and then when
that was exposed
the vice president said when asked well
why didn't you all tell anybody
he said because the president wanted
people to remain
calm well let's go but susan
this is important and i want to add but
if mr vice president i'm speaking i have
i'm speaking
yeah you can have 15 more seconds and
then we'll give the vice president
so i want to ask the american people how
calm were you when you were panicked
about where you're going to get your
next roll of toilet paper
how calm were you when your kids were
sent home from school and you didn't
know when they could go back
how kind thank you thank you when your
children couldn't see your parents
because you were afraid they could kill
them let's give vice president pence a
chance to respond vice presidents you
have one minute to receive you know
there's not a day gone by that i haven't
thought of every american family that's
lost a loved one
and i want all of you to know that
you'll always be in our hearts
and in our prayers but when you say what
the american people have done over these
last eight months hasn't
worked that's a great disservice
to the sacrifices the american people
have made
the reality if i may if i may finish
that
the reality is dr fauci said everything
that he told the president in the oval
office the president told the american
people
now president trump i will tell you has
boundless confidence in the american
people and he always spoke with
confidence that we'd get through this
together
but when you say it hasn't worked when
dr fauci and dr burks and our medical
experts came to us in the second week of
march
they said if the president didn't take
the unprecedented step
of shutting down roughly half of the
american economy that we could lose 2.2
million americans that's the reality
thank you they also said this if we did
everything right susan we could still
lose more than 200 000 americans
vice president one life lost is too many
susan
but the american people i believe
deserve credit
for the sacrifices that they have made
putting the health of their family
and their neighbors first our doctors
our nurses our first thank you vice
president pence and i'm going to speak
up on behalf of what the american people
have done
vice president pence you were in the
front row in a rose garden event 11 days
ago
what seems to have been a super spreader
event for senior administration and
congressional officials
no social distancing few masks and now
a cluster of coronavirus cases among
those who were there
how can you expect americans to follow
the administration's safety guidelines
to protect themselves from covid
when you at the white house have not
been doing so
well the american people have
demonstrated
over the last eight months that when
given the facts
they're willing to put the health of
their families and their neighbors and
people they don't even know
first president trump and i have great
confidence in in the american people and
and their ability to take that
information
and put it into practice in the height
of the epidemic
when we were losing a heartbreaking
number of
2500 americans a day we surged resources
to new jersey and
new york and new orleans and detroit we
told the american people what needed to
be done and the american people made the
sacrifices
when the outbreak in the sun belt
happened this summer again americans
stepped forward
but the reality is the work of the
president of the united states goes on
a vacancy on the supreme court of the
united states
uh has come upon us and the president
introduced judge amy coney
thank you thank you very much if i may
say that rose garden event
there's been a great deal of speculation
about it my wife karen and i were there
and honored to be there
many of the people who were at that
event susan actually were tested for
coronavirus
and it was an outdoor event which all of
our scientists regularly and routinely
advise
the difference here is president trump
and i trust the american people
to make choices in the best interest of
their health
joe biden and kamala harris consistently
talk about
mandates and not not just mandates with
the coronavirus but
a government takeover of healthcare
thank you thank you green new deal
all government control we're about
freedom and respecting the freedom of
the american people
let's talk about respecting the american
people you respect the american people
when you tell them the truth you respect
the american people when you have the
courage
to be a leader speaking of those things
that you may not want people to hear but
they need to hear so they can protect
themselves
but this administration stood on
information that if you had as a parent
if you had as a worker knowing you
didn't have enough money saved up
and now you're standing in a food line
because of the ineptitude
of a administration that was unwilling
to speak the truth to the american
people
so let's talk about caring about the
american people the american people have
had to sacrifice far too much
because of the incompetence of this
administration it is asking too much of
the people
who are talking about that asking too
much of the people
that they would not be equipped with the
information they need
to help themselves to protect their
parents president and they're sorry
uh senator harris i mean i'm sorry
that's fine i'm comma no no you're
senator harris to me
for life to get back to normal dr
anthony fauci and other experts say
that most of the people who can be
vaccinated need to be vaccinated
but half of americans now say they
wouldn't take a vaccine if it was
released now
if the trump administration approves a
vaccine before or after the election
should americans take it and would you
take it
if the public health professionals if dr
fauci if the doctors tell us that we
should take it i'll be the first in line
to take it absolutely but if donald
trump tells us i should
that we should take it i'm not taking it
vice president pence there have been a
lot of repercussions
from this pandemic in recent days the
president's diagnosis of covert 19 has
underscored the importance
of the job that you hold and that you
are seeking
that's our second topic tonight it's the
role of the vice president
one of you will make history on january
20th we will be the vice president to
the
oldest president the united states has
ever had
donald trump will be 74 years old on
inauguration day
joe biden will be 78 years old that
already has raised concerns among some
voters
concerns that have been sharpened by
president trump's hospitalization in
recent days
vice president pence have you had a
conversation
or reached an agreement with president
trump about
safeguards or procedures when it comes
to the issue
of presidential disability and if not
do you think you should you have two
minutes without interruption
well susan uh thank you although i would
like to go back
i think we need to move on well thank
you but i would like to go back
because the reality is that we're going
to have a vaccine
senator in record time in unheard of
time in less than a year
we have five companies in phase three
clinical trials
and we're right now producing tens of
millions of doses
so the fact that you continue to
undermine public confidence in a vaccine
if the vaccine emerges during the trump
administration i think is
is unconscionable and senator i just ask
you
stop playing politics with people's
lives the reality
is that we will have a vaccine we
believe before the end of this year
and it will have the capacity to save
countless american lives and
and your continuous undermining
of confidence in a vaccine is just it's
just
unacceptable and let me also say you
know the reality is when you talk about
about failure in this administration we
actually do know what failure looks like
in a pandemic
it was 2009 the swine flu arrived in the
united states
thankfully it was ended up not being as
lethal
as the coronavirus but before the end of
the year
when joe biden was vice president of the
united states
not seven and a half million people
contracted the swine flu
60 million americans contracted the
swine flu
if the swine flu had been as lethal as
the coronavirus in 2009
when joe biden was vice president we
would have lost 2 million american lives
his own chief of staff ron klain would
say last year
that it was pure luck that they did
quote
everything possible wrong and
and we learned from that they left the
strategic national stockpile
empty they left uh an empty and hollow
plan
but we still learn from it and i i think
the american people i'm gonna say again
can be
vice president pence i'm sorry what
could we have done and senator please
stop undermining confidence in a vaccine
senator harris let me ask you the same
question
that i asked vice president pence which
is have you had a conversation
or reached an agreement with vice
president biden about
safeguards or procedures when it comes
to the issue
of presidential disability and if not
and if you win the election next month
do you think you should you have two
minutes uninterrupted
so let me tell you first of all um the
day i got the call from
from joe biden it was actually a zoom
call
asking me to serve with him on this
ticket was probably one of the most
memorable
memorable days of my life um i you know
i thought about my mother who came to
the united states at the age of 19.
gave birth to me at the age of 25 at
kaiser hospital in oakland california
and the thought that i'd be sitting here
right now
i know would make her proud and she must
be looking down on this
you know joe and i were raised in a very
similar way
we were raised with values that are
about hard work
about the value and the dignity of
public service
and about the importance of fighting for
the dignity of all people
and i think joe asked me to serve with
him because
you know i have a career that included
being elected the first woman district
attorney
of san francisco where i created models
of
innovation for for law enforcement in
terms of reform of the criminal justice
system i was elected
the first woman of color and black woman
to be
elected attorney general of the state of
california where i ran the second
largest department of justice in the
united states
second only to the united states
department of justice and there i took
on
everything from transnational criminal
organizations to the big banks that were
taking advantage of homeowners
to for-profit colleges that were taking
advantage of veterans
and then of course now i serve in the
united states senate is only the second
black woman ever elected
to the united states senate i serve on
the senate intelligence committee where
i've been in
regular receipt of classified
information about
threats to our nation and hot spots
around the world i've traveled the world
i've met
with our soldiers in our in war zones
and i think joe has asked me to serve
with him because he knows that we
share we share a purpose which is about
lifting up the american people
and after the four years that we have
seen of donald trump
unifying our country around our common
values
and principles thank you senator harris
you know neither neither
president trump nor vice president biden
has released a sort of detailed
health information that had become the
modern norm until the 2016 election
and in recent days president trump's
doctors have given misleading answers or
refused to answer basic questions about
his health
and my question to each of you in turn
is
is this information voters deserve
to know vice president pence would you
like to go first
well susan thank you and uh
and let me let me say on behalf of the
president
and the first lady how moved we've all
been
by the outpouring of prayers and concern
for the president and i do believe it's
emblematic of the prayers and
the concern that have ushered forth for
every american impacted
by the coronavirus but the care the
president received
at walter reed hospital the white house
doctors was exceptional
and the transparency that they practiced
all along the way will continue
the american people have a right to know
about the health and well-being
of their president and we'll continue to
do that
but i'm just extremely grateful and was
more than more than a little moved by
the broad and bipartisan support and
senator i want to thank you and joe
biden for your expressions genuine
concern
and i also want to congratulate you uh
as i did on that phone call
uh on the historic nature of your
nomination
um i i never expected to be on this
stage four years ago so
i know the feeling but um the reality is
uh we've got an election before the
american people in the midst of this
challenging year
and the stakes have never been higher
but i think the choice has never been i
want to
give senator harris a chance to respond
to the same question i ask which is do
voters have a right to know
more detailed health information about
presidential candidates and especially
about presidents
especially when they're facing some kind
of challenge absolutely and that's why
joe biden has been
so incredibly transparent and certainly
by contrast
um the president has not um both in
terms of
health records but also let's look at
taxes we now know because of
great investigative journalism that
donald trump paid
750 dollars in taxes when i first heard
about it
i i literally said you mean 750 000
and it was like no 750 dollars
we now know donald trump owes
and is in debt for 400 million dollars
and just so everyone is clear when when
we say in debt
it means you owe money to somebody and
it'd be really good to know
who the president of the united states
the commander-in-chief
owes money to because the american
people have a right to know
what is influencing the president's
decisions and is he making those
decisions on the best interest of the
american people of you
or self-interest so susan i'm glad you
asked about transparency
because it has to be across the board
joe has been incredibly transparent
over many many years the one thing we
all know about joe
he puts it all out there he he is
honest he is forthright but donald trump
on the other hand
has been about covering up everything
thanks thank you senator harris i want
to give you a chance to respond
vice president well look i i respect the
fact that joe biden spent 47 years in
public life
i respect your public service as well
thank you
the american people have a president who
was a businessman
it's a job creator who's paid
tens of millions of dollars in taxes
payroll taxes property taxes he's
created tens of thousands of american
jobs
and the president said those public
reports are not accurate
and the president's also released
literally stacks of financial
disclosures the american people can
review just as the law allows but the
distinction here
is that joe biden 47 years in
public service compared to president
donald trump who brought all of that
experience four years ago thank you very
much thank you very much turned this
economy around by cutting taxes
rolling back regulations thank you thank
you very much energy
fighting for free and fair trade and all
that thank you vice president if joe
biden
and kamal harris you know that's a good
segue into our third topic
which is about the economy this has been
another
aspect of life for americans it's been
so affected
by this coronavirus we have a jobs
crisis
brewing on friday we learned that the
unemployment rate had declined to 7.9
percent in september
but the job growth had stalled and that
was before the latest round of layoffs
and furloughs
in the airline industry at disney and
elsewhere hundreds of thousands of
discouraged workers have stopped looking
for work
nearly 11 million jobs that existed at
the beginning of the year
haven't been replaced those hardest hit
include latinos
blacks and women senator harris the
biden harris
campaign has proposed new programs to
boost the economy and you would pay for
that
new spending by raising four trillion
dollars
in taxes on wealthy individuals and
corporations
some economists warn that could curb
entrepreneurial ventures
that fuel growth and create jobs would
raising
taxes put the recovery at risk and you
have two minutes to answer
uninterrupted thank you
on the issue of the economy i think
there couldn't be a more fundamental
difference
between donald trump and joe biden
joe biden believes you measure the
health and the strength of america's
economy
based on the health and the strength of
the american worker
and the american family on the other
hand you have donald trump
who measures the strength of the economy
based on how rich people are doing
which is why he passed a tax bill
benefiting the top one percent
and the biggest corporations of america
leading to
a two trillion dollar deficit that the
american people are going to have to pay
for
on day one joe biden will repeal that
tax bill he'll get rid of it
and what he'll do with the money is
invest it in the american people
and through a plan that is about
investing in infrastructure something
that donald trump said he would do i
remember hearing about some
infrastructure week i don't think it
ever happened but joe biden will do that
he'll invest in infrastructure it's
about upgrading our roads and bridges
but also
investing in clean energy and renewable
energy joe is going to
invest that money in what we need to do
around innovation
there was a time when our country
believed in science
and invested in research and development
so that we were
an innovation leader on the globe joe
biden will use that money to invest in
education
so for example for folks who want to go
to a two-year community college it will
be free
if you come from a family that makes
less than 125
000 you'll go to a public university for
free
and across the board will make sure that
if you have student loan debt it's cut
by ten thousand dollars
that's how joe biden thinks about the
economy which is it's about
investing in the people of our country
as opposed to passing a tax bill
which had the benefit of letting
american corporations
go offshore to do their business
thank you senator harris vice president
pence your administration has been
predicting a rapid and robust
recovery but the latest economic report
suggests that's not happening
should americans be braced for an
economic comeback that is going to take
not months but a year
or more you have two minutes to answer
uninterrupted
when president trump and i took office
america had gone through the slowest
economic recovery since the great
depression as when joe biden was vice
president they tried to tax and spend
and regulate
and bail our way back to a growing
economy president trump cut taxes
across the board despite what senator
harris says
the average american family of four had
two thousand dollars in savings in taxes
and with the rise in wages that occurred
most predominantly for blue-collar
hard-working americans
the average household income for a
family of four increased by
thousand dollars following president
trump's tax cuts
but america you just heard senator
harris tell you on day one
joe biden's going to raise your taxes
it's really remarkable to thanks
i mean right after a time where we're
going through a pandemic that lost
22 million jobs at the height we've
already added back 11.6 million jobs
because we had a president who cut taxes
rolled back regulation unleashed
american energy fought for free and fair
trade and secured four
trillion dollars from the congress of
the united states to give direct
payments to families
save 50 million jobs through the
paycheck protection program
we literally have spared no expense to
help the american people in the american
worker through
this joe biden and kamala harris want to
raise
taxes they want to bury our economy
under a two trillion dollar green new
deal
which you were one of the original
co-sponsors of in the united states
senate
they want to abolish fossil fuels and
ban fracking which would cost
hundreds of thousands of american jobs
all across the heartland
and joe biden wants to go back to the
economic surrender to china that when we
took office
half of our international trade deficit
was with china alone
and joe biden wants to repeal all of the
tariffs that president trump put into
effect to fight for american jobs and
american workers
joe biden says democracy's on the ballot
make no mistake about it susan
the american economy the american
comeback is on
the ballot with four more years of
growth thank you an opportunity four
more years of president donald trump
2021 thank you very much biggest
economic year in the history of this
country thank you vice president pence
senator harris well i mean i that we saw
enough of it in last week's debate but i
think this is supposed to be a debate
based on fact and truth and the truth
and the fact is
joe biden has been very clear he will
not raise taxes on anybody who makes
less than
hundred thousand dollars a year appeal
the trump tax cut mr vice president i'm
speaking
i'm speaking be important if you said
the truth
joe biden said twice in the debate last
week that he's going to repeal the trump
tax cuts
that was tax cuts that gave the average
working family
two thousand dollars in a tax break
every single year that senator
that is absolutely not true that is he
only cutting
is he only going to repeal part of the
trump tax cuts if you don't mind letting
me finish
we can then have a conversation okay
please okay
joe biden will not raise taxes on anyone
who makes less than 400
000 a year he has been very clear about
that joe biden will not end fracking he
has been very clear about that
joe biden is the one who
during the the great recession was
responsible
for the recovery act that brought
america back and now the trump hence
administration wants to take credit
when they ran when they wrote the court
coattails of joe biden's success
for the economy that they had at the
beginning of their term of course now
the economy is a complete disaster
but joe biden on the one hand did that
on the other hand you have donald trump
who has reigned over a recession
that is being compared to the great
depression on the one hand you have joe
biden
who was responsible with president
barack obama
for the affordable care act which
brought health care to over 20
million americans and protected people
with pre-existing conditions and what it
also did
is it saved those families who otherwise
were going bankrupt
because of hospital bills they could not
afford on the other hand
you have donald trump who's in court
right now trying to get rid of
thank you trying to get rid of the
affordable care act
which means that you will lose
protections if you have pre-existing
conditions and i just this is very
important susan yes and it's about we
need to give
we need to get vice president i'd just
like he interrupted me and i'd like to
just finish
please if you have a pre-existing
condition
heart disease diabetes breast cancer
they're coming for you
if you love someone who has a
pre-existing condition thank you thank
you
coming for you if you are under the age
of 26 on your parents coverage
they're coming for you senator harris
thank you let me give you a chance to
respond
well i hope we have a chance to talk
about health care because obamacare was
a disaster
the american people remember it well and
president trump and i have a plan
to improve health care and to protect
protect pre-existing conditions for
every
american but look senator harris you're
you're entitled to your own opinion but
you're not entitled to your own facts
you yourself said on multiple occasions
when you were running for president
that you would ban fracking joe biden
looked at a supporter in the eye
and pointed and said i guarantee i
guarantee
that we will abolish fossil fuels they
have a two trillion dollar version of
the green new deal susan that your
newspaper usa today said
really wasn't that very different from
the original green new deal
more taxes more regulation banning
fracking
abolishing fossil fuel crushing american
energy
and economics surrendered china is a
prescription for
economic decline president trump and i
will keep
america growing the v-shaped recovery
that's underway
right now will continue with four more
years of president donald trump
thank you very very much vice president
pence once again you've provided the
perfect segue to a new topic
which is climate change and vice
president pence i'd like to pose the
first question
to you this year we've seen
record-setting hurricanes in the south
another one hurricane delta is now
threatening the gulf
and we have seen record-setting
wildfires in the west
do you believe as the scientific
community has concluded
that man-made climate change has made
wildfires bigger
hotter and more deadly and have made
hurricanes wetter
slower and more damaging you have two
minutes
uninterrupted thank you susan well first
i'm very proud of our record on the
environment and on conservation
according to all of the best estimates
are
our air and land are cleaner than any
time ever recorded
our water is among the cleanest in the
world and just a little while ago the
president signed the outdoors act as the
largest investment in our public lands
and public parks
in a hundred years so president trump
has made a commitment to conservation
into the environment
now with regard to climate change the
climate is changing
but the issue is what's the cause
and what do we do about it president
trump has made it clear that we're going
to continue to listen to the science
now joe biden and kamala harris would
put us back in the
paris climate accord they'd impose the
green new deal
which would crush american energy would
increase the energy costs of american
families in their homes and literally
would crush
american jobs and president trump and i
believe that
the progress that we have made in a
cleaner environment
has been happening precisely because we
have a strong
free market economy you know what's
remarkable is
the united states has reduced co2
more than the countries that are still
in the paris climate accord but we've
done it through innovation
and we've done it through natural gas
and fracking
which senator the american people can go
look at the record i
i know joe biden says otherwise now as
you do
but the both of you repeatedly committed
to abolishing fossil fuel and banning
a fracking and so by creating the kind
of american innovation
we're actually steering toward a
stronger and better environment
with regard to wildfires president trump
and i believe that forest management has
to be front and center and even
governor gavin newsom from your state
has agreed we've got to work on forest
management
and with regard to hurricanes the
national
oceanic administration tells us that
actually is as difficult as they are
thank you vice president there are no
more hurricanes today than there were a
hundred years ago
thank you but many of the climate alarms
use hurricanes and wildfires
to try and sell those goods of a green
new deal
and president trump and i are going to
always put american jobs and american
workers
first senator harris as the vice
president mentioned you co-sponsored the
green new deal
in congress but vice president biden
said in last week's debate
that he does not support the green new
deal but if you look at the biden harris
campaign website it describes the
greener deal as a crucial framework
what exactly would be the stance of a
biden harris administration
toward the green new deal you have two
minutes uninterrupted
sure so first of all i will repeat
and the american people know that joe
biden will not
ban fracking that is a fact that is a
fact
i will repeat that joe biden has been
very clear
that he thinks about growing jobs which
is why he
will not increase taxes for anyone who
makes less than four hundred thousand
dollars a year
joe biden's economic plan moody's
which is a reputable wall street firm
has said will create seven million more
jobs
than donald trump's and part of those
jobs that will be created by joe biden
are going to be about clean energy and
renewable energy
because you see joe understands that
the west coast of our country is burning
including my home state of california
joe sees what is happening on the gulf
states
which are being battered by storms joe
has seen
and talked with the farmers in iowa
whose entire crops have been destroyed
because of floods
and so joe believes again in science
i'll tell you something susan i served
when i first got to the senate
on the committee that's responsible for
the environment do you know this
administration
took the word science off the website
and then took the phrase climate change
off the website
this we have seen a pattern with this
administration which is they don't
believe in science
and joe's plan is about saying we're
going to deal with it but we're also
going to create jobs
donald trump when asked about the
wildfires in california
and and the question was you know the
science is telling us this you know what
donald trump said
science doesn't know so
let's talk about who is prepared to lead
our country
over the course of the next four years
on what is an existential threat
to us as human beings joe is about
saying we're going to invest that in
renewable energy
it's going to be about the creation of
millions of jobs we will achieve
net zero emissions by 2050 carbon
neutral by 2035
joe has a plan this has been a lot of
talk from the trump administration and
really it has been to go backward
instead of forward
we will also re-enter the climate
agreement with pride
senator harris just said that climate
change is an existential threat
vice president pence do you believe that
climate change poses an existential
threat
as i said susan the climate is changing
we'll follow the science
but once again uh senator harris
is denying the fact that they're going
to raise taxes
on every american joe biden said twice
in the debate last week
that on day one he was going to repeal
the trump tax cuts
those tax cuts delivered two thousand
dollars in tax relief
to the average family of four across
america and with regard to banning
fracking i just recommend that people
look at the record you yourself said
repeatedly that you would ban fracking
you were the first
senate co-sponsor of the green new deal
and while joe biden denied the green new
deal susan thank you for pointing out
the green new deal is on their campaign
website and as usa today said
it's essentially the same plan as you
co-sponsored
with aoc when she submitted it in the
senate and you just heard the senator
say that she's going to resubmit
america to the paris climate accord look
the american people have always
cherished our environment we'll continue
to cherish it we've made great progress
reducing co2 emissions through american
innovation
and the development of natural gas
through fracking we don't
need a massive 2 trillion dollar green
new deal that would impose
all new mandates on american businesses
and american families
thank you joe biden wants us to retrofit
4 million
thank you vice president business
buildings it makes no sense it will cost
jobs president trump thank you very much
america first he's going to put jobs
first and we're going to take
care of our environment and follow the
sciences thank you so on the issue of
jobs senator
let's talk about that you the the vice
president earlier referred to
as part of what he thinks is an
accomplishment
um the the president's trade war with
china
you lost that trade war you lost it
what ended up happening is because of a
so-called trade war with china
america lost 300 000 manufacturing jobs
farmers have experienced bankruptcy
because of it we are in a manufacturing
recession
because of it and when we look at
where this administration has been there
are estimates that by the end of the
term
of this administration they will have
lost more jobs
than almost any other presidential
administration
and the american people know what i'm
talking about you know
i i think about 20 year olds you know we
have a 20 year old
20 something year old who are coming out
of high school in college right now and
you're wondering
is there going to be a job there for me
we're looking at people who are
trying to figure out how they're going
to pay rent by the end of the month
almost half of american renters
are worried about whether they're going
to be able to pay rent by the end of the
month
this is where the economy is in america
right now
and it is because of the catastrophe
and the failure of leadership of this
administration
thank you senator harris vice president
pence let me give you just 15 seconds to
respond because then i want to move on
to well i i'd
love to respond look lost the
trade war with china joe biden never
fought it
joe biden's been a cheerleader for
communist china through
over the last several decades and and
again
senator harris you're entitled to your
opinion you're not entitled to your own
facts
when joe biden was vice president we
lost 200 000
manufacturing jobs and president obama
said they were never coming back he said
we needed a magic wand to bring them
back
in our first three years after we cut
taxes rollback regulation unleashed
american energy
this administration saw five hundred
thousand manufacturing jobs
created and that's exactly the kind of
growth we're going to continue to see as
we bring our nation through thank you
very much pandemic
the green new deal your massive new
mandate your paris climate accord
it's going to kill jobs this time just
like it killed jobs i just need to
respond very much
15 seconds thank you thank you
joe biden is responsible for saving
america's auto industry and you voted
against it
so let's set the record straight thank
you
i'd like to talk about china we have as
our next
topic we have no more complicated or
consequential
foreign relationship than the one with
china it is
a huge market for american agricultural
goods it's a
potential partner in dealing with
climate change in north korea
and in a video tonight president trump
again blamed it
for the coronavirus saying china will
pay
vice president pence how would you
describe our
our fundamental relationship with china
competitors
adversaries enemies you have two minutes
thank you susan well let me before i
leave that let me let me speak to voting
records if i can
you know everybody knows that nafta cost
literally
thousands of american factories to close
we saw automotive jobs go south of the
border president trump
fought to renegotiate nafta in the
united states mexico canada agreement is
now the law of the land
american people deserve to know senator
kamala harris was one of only 10 members
of the senate to vote against the usmca
it was a huge win for american auto
workers it was a huge win for american
farmers especially dairy in the upper
midwest
but senator you you said it didn't go
far enough on climate change
that that you put your your radical
environmental agenda
ahead of american auto workers and ahead
of american
jobs and the american people deserve to
know that is probably why
newsweek magazine said that that kamala
harris was the most
liberal member of the united states
senate in 2019
more liberal than bernie sanders uh more
more liberal than
any of the others in the united states
senate so
now with regard to china look
susan first and foremost
china is to blame for the coronavirus
and president trump is not happy about
it he's made that very clear made it
clear again today
china and the world health organization
did not play straight with the american
people
they did not let our personnel into
china
to get information on the coronavirus
until the middle of february
fortunately president trump in dealing
with china from the outset of this
administration standing up to china that
had been taking advantage of america for
decades
in the wake of joe biden's cheerleading
for china
president trump made that decision
before the end of january to suspend
all travel from china and again the
american people deserve to know joe
biden opposed president trump's decision
to suspend all travel
from china he said it was hysterical he
said thank you vice president
of president trump china we're going to
continue to stand strong
thank you vice president we want to
improve the relationship but we're going
to level the playing field and we're
going to hold china accountable for what
they did to america
with the coronavirus thank you senator
harris let me ask you the same
question that i asked the vice president
how would you describe
our fundamental relationship with china
are we competitors
adversaries enemies you'll have two
minutes
uninterrupted susan the
trump administration's
perspective and approach to china has
resulted in the loss of american lives
american jobs and america's
standing there is a weird obsession
that president trump has had with
getting rid of whatever
accomplishment was achieved by president
obama and vice president biden
for example they created within the
white house
an office that basically was responsible
for monitoring pandemics
they got away they got rid of it it's
not true
there was a team of disease
experts that president obama
and vice president biden dispatched to
china
to monitor what is now predictable
and what might happen they pulled them
out we now are looking
at 210 000 americans who have lost their
lives
let's look at the job situation we
mentioned before
the trade deal the trade war they wanted
to call it with china
it resulted in the loss of over 300
manufacturing jobs and a manufacturing
recession
and the american consumer paying
thousands of dollars more for goods
because of that failed war that they
called it
then let's talk about standing pew a
reputable
research firm has done an analysis
that shows that leaders of all of our
formerly allied countries have now
decided
that they hold in greater esteem and
respect
xi jinping the head of the chinese
communist party
then they do donald trump the president
of the united states the
commander-in-chief of the united states
this is where we are today because of a
failure of leadership by this
administration
senator harris we've seen changes in the
in the role of the united states in
terms of global leadership
over the past four years and of course
times do change
what's your definition we've seen
strains with china of course
as the vice president mentioned we've
seen strange with our traditional allies
in nato and elsewhere what is your
definition of the role of american
leadership
in 2020 so
you know joe is i love talking with joe
about a lot of these issues and you know
joe
he i think he said it quite well he says
you know foreign policy it might
sound complicated but really it's
relationships so just think about it as
relationships
and so we know this in our personal and
professional relationships um
you got to keep your word to your
friends gotta be loyal to your friends
people who've stood with you
gotta stand with them you gotta know who
your adversaries are
and keep them in check but what we have
seen
with donald trump is that he has
betrayed our friends and it and
and and and and embraced dictators
around the world
let's take for example russia
so rush i serve on the intelligence
committee
of the united states senate america's
intelligence community told
us russia interfered in the election of
the president of the united states in
2016 and is playing in 2020.
christopher wray the director of the fbi
said the same
but donald trump the commander-in-chief
of the united states of america
prefers to take the word of vladimir
putin over the word of the american
intelligence community
you look at our friends at nato
he has walked away from agreements you
can talk look at the iran nuclear deal
which now has put us in a position
where we are less safe because they are
building up
what might end up being a significant
nuclear
arsenal we were in that deal guys we
were in the iran nuclear deal with
friends with allies around the country
and because of donald trump's unilateral
approach to foreign policy
coupled with his isolationism he pulled
us
out and has made america less safe so
susan it's about relationships
and the thing that has always been part
of the strength of our nation
in addition to our great military has
been that we keep our word but donald
trump doesn't understand that
because he doesn't understand what it
means to be honest
thank you thank you uh thank you senator
harris vice president
let me give you a chance to respond well
thank you um well president trump kept
his word when we moved the american
embassy to jerusalem
the capital of the state of israel when
joe biden was vice president they
promised to do that and they never did
we've stood strong with our allies but
we've been demanding
nato is now contributing more to our
common defense than
ever before thanks to president trump's
leadership
we've strengthened our alliances across
the asia pacific
and we've stood strong against those who
would do us harm
you know when president trump came into
office isis had
captured an area of the middle east the
size of pennsylvania
but president trump unleashed the
american military
and our armed forces destroyed the isis
caliphate
and took down their leader al baghdadi
without one american casualty
al baghdadi was uh responsible
for the death of thousands um
but notably america's hearts today are
with the family of kayla mueller
your parents which are here with us
tonight in salt lake city
today two of the isis killers
responsible for kayla mueller's murder
were brought to justice in the united
states
jihadi john was killed on the
battlefield along with the other
beetle the reality is that
when joe biden was vice president we had
an opportunity
to save kayla miller breaks my heart to
reflect on it but the military came into
the oval office
presented a plan they said they knew
where caleb was
baghdadi had held her for 18 months
abused her mercilessly before they
killed her but when joe biden was vice
president they hesitated
for a month and when armed forces
finally went in
it was clear she'd been moved two days
earlier and her family
says with a heart that broke the heart
of every american that
if president donald trump had been
president they believe kayla would be
alive today
thank you very much we destroyed the
isis caliphate
uh and you talk about re-entering the
iran nuclear deal i mean the last
administration transferred 1.8 billion
dollars
to the leading state sponsor thank you
very much of terrorism
president donald trump got us out of the
department thank you vice president and
and when qasim solomoni was traveling to
baghdad thank you
harm to americans president donald trump
thank you vice president pence and
america is is safer
our allies are safer and the american
people know president donald trump will
never thank you vice president take
action i would like to give
senator harris a chance to respond but
not at such great length because of
course there are other topics we want to
talk about but i would like equal time
yes thank you please go ahead first of
all to the
mueller family i i know about your
daughter's case
and i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
um what happened to her is awful
and it should have never happened and i
know joe feels the same way
and i know that president obama feels
the same way
um but you mentioned solemani let's
let's start there
so after the strike on solemani there
was a counter
strike on our troops in iraq
and they suffered
serious brain injuries and do you know
what donald trump dismissed them as
headaches and this is about a pattern of
donald trump's
where he has referred to our
men who are serving in our military as
suckers and losers
donald trump who went to arlington
cemetery
and stood above the graves of our
fallen heroes and said
what's in it for them because of course
you know he only thinks about what's in
it for him let's take
what he said about john mccain a great
american hero and
and donald trump says he doesn't deserve
to be called a hero
because he was a prisoner of war
take and this is this is very important
when you want to talk about
who is the current commander-in-chief
and what they care about and what they
don't care about
public reporting that russia had
bounties on the heads
of american soldiers and you know what a
bounty is
it's somebody puts a price on your head
and they will pay it if you are
killed and donald trump had talked at
least six times
to vladimir putin and never brought up
the subject
joe biden would never do that thank you
joe biden would but joe biden
would hold russia to account for any
threat
to our nation's security or to our
troops
who are sacrificing their lives for the
sake of our democracy and our safety
thank you
senator harris this is such an important
issue but we have other important issues
as well and i want to i want to make
sure we have a chance i really have to
talk about
that she has 15 seconds because well i
gotta
try to keep looking i'm sorry but vice
president you've had more time than
she's had
so far offenders against president
donald trump
regarding men and women of our armed
forces are absurd
i'm sorry my son is a captain in the
united states marine corps
my son-in-law is deployed in the united
states navy
i can assure all of you with sons and
daughters serving in our military
president donald trump not only respects
but reveres
all of those who serve in our armed
forces and any suggestion otherwise
it's ridiculous thank you vice president
american people deserve susan's
american people i didn't know
agreed to the rules for tonight's debate
with the commission on presidential base
i'm here to enforce them which involves
moving from one topic to another
giving roughly equal time to both of you
which is what i'm trying very hard to go
right ahead so i want to go ahead and
move to the next topic which is an
important one
as the last topic was and that is the
supreme court
on monday the senate judiciary committee
is scheduled to open hearings on amy
coney barrett's nomination to the
supreme court senator harris
you'll be there as a member of the
committee her confirmation would cement
the court's conservative majority
and make it likely open to more abortion
restrictions
even to overturning the landmark roe v
wade ruling
access to abortion would then be up to
the states
vice president pence you're the former
governor of indiana
if roe v wade is overturned what would
you want
indiana to do would you want your home
state to ban
all abortions you have two minutes
uninterrupted well thank you for the
question but i'll use a little bit of my
time to respond to that very important
issue before the american people deserve
to know
qasim salamani the iranian general was
responsible for the death of
hundreds of american service members
when the opportunity came we saw him
headed to baghdad to
kill more americans president trump
didn't hesitate
and qasim salamani is gone but you
deserve to know that joe biden
and kamala harris actually criticized
the decision to take out solomon
qasim salamani it's really inexplicable
but
with regard to joe biden it's it's
explainable
because history records that joe biden
actually opposed the raid against osama
bin laden
it's absolutely essential that we have a
commander-in-chief
who will not hesitate to act to protect
american lives
and to protect american service members
and that's what you have in president
donald trump
now with regard to the supreme court of
the united states
let me say president trump and i could
not be more enthusiastic
about the opportunity to see judge amy
coney barrett become justice amy coney
barrett
she's a brilliant woman and she will
bring a lifetime of experience and
a sizable american family to the supreme
court of the united states
and our hope is in the hearing next week
unlike justice kavanaugh received with
treatment from you and others
we hope she gets a fair hearing and we
particularly hope that we don't see the
kind of attacks on her
christian faith that we saw before i
mean the
democrat chairman of the judiciary
committee before
when when judge barrett was being
confirmed for the court of appeals
expressed concern that the
dogma of her faith lived loudly in her
dick durbin of illinois said that it was
a concern
senator i know one of our judicial
nominees you actually
attacked because they were a member of
the catholic knights of columbus
just because the knights of columbus
holds pro-life views
thank you thank you thank you vice
president for your time when the hearing
takes place
thank you vice president pence that
judge amy coney barrett will be
respected thank you vice president
voted and confirmed to the supreme court
of the united states senator harris
you're the senator from and former
attorney general of california so let me
ask you a parallel question to the one i
posed to the vice president
if roe v wade is overturned what would
you want
california to do would you want your
home state to enact no restrictions
on access to abortion and you have two
minutes
uninterrupted thank you susan first of
all
joe biden and i are both people of faith
and it's insulting to suggest that we
would
knock anyone for their faith and in fact
joe
if elected will be only the second
practicing catholic as president of the
united
states um on the issue of this
of this nomination joe and i
are very clear as are the majority of
the american people we are
27 days before the decision about who
will
be the next president of the united
states and you know before
when this conversation has come up you
know it's been about election year or
election time
we're literally in an election
over four million people have voted
people are in the process of voting
right now
and so joe has been very clear as the
american people are
let the american people fill that seat
in the white house
and then we'll fill that seat on the
united states supreme court and to your
point susan that
the issues before us couldn't be more
serious there's the issue of choice
and i will always fight for a woman's
right to make a decision about her
own body it should be her decision and
not that of donald trump
and the vice president michael pence but
let's also look at what else is before
the
the court it's the affordable care act
like
literally in the midst of a public
health pandemic
when over 210 000 people have died
and seven million people probably have
what will be in the future considered a
pre-existing condition because you
you contracted the virus donald trump is
in court right now trying to get rid of
the affordable care act
and i said it before and it bears
repeating
this means that there will be no more
protections if they win
for people with pre-existing conditions
this
means that over 20 million people will
lose your coverage
it means that if you're under the age of
26 you can't stay on your parents
coverage anymore
and here's the thing the contrast
couldn't be more clear
they're trying to get rid of the
affordable care act joe biden is saying
let's expand coverage
let's give you a choice of a public
option or private coverage
let's bring down thank you senator let's
lower medicare eligibility to 60.
thank you senator that's true leadership
you know you mentioned
uh earlier vice president pence that the
president was committed
to maintaining protections for people
with pre-existing conditions
um and but you do have this court case
that you are supporting your
administration supporting
that would strike down the affordable
care act the the president
says president trump says that he's
going to protect people with
pre-existing
conditions but he has not explained how
he would do that
and that was one of the toughest nuts to
crack when they were passing the
affordable care act so tell us
specifically how would your
administration protect americans with
pre-existing conditions have
access to affordable insurance if the
affordable care act
is struck down well thank you susan
but let me just say addressing your very
first question
i couldn't be more proud to serve as
vice president to a president who stands
without apology for the sanctity of
human life
i'm pro-life i i don't apologize for it
and this is another one of those cases
where there's such a dramatic
contrast joe biden and kamala harris
support
taxpayer funding of abortion all the way
up to the moment of birth
late term abortion they want to increase
funding to planned parenthood
of america now for our part i i would
never presume how judge amy coney
barrett
would rule on the supreme court of the
united states but
will continue to stand strong for the
right to life when you speak about the
supreme court though i think the
american people really deserve an answer
senator harris
are you and joe biden going to pack the
court if judge amy coney barrett has
confirmed
i mean there have been 29 vacancies on
the supreme court during presidential
election
years from george washington to barack
obama presidents have nominated in all
29 cases
but your party is actually openly
advocating
adding seats to the supreme court which
has had nine seats for 150 years
if you don't get your way this is a
classic case of if you can't win by the
rules
you're going to change the rules now
you've refused to answer the question
joe biden has refused to answer the
question so i think the american people
would really like to know
if judge amy coney barrett is confirmed
with the supreme court of the united
states
are you and joe biden if somehow you win
this election going to
pack the supreme court to get your way
i'm so glad we went through a little
history lesson let's do that a little
more
in 1816 i'd like you to answer the
question mr vice president
speaking i'm speaking okay
in 1864 one of the
i think political heroes certainly of
the president i assume if you
also mr vice president is abraham
lincoln
abraham lincoln was up for re-election
and it was 27 days before the election
and a seat became open on the united
states supreme court
abraham lincoln's party was in charge
not only of the white house but the
senate
but honest aid said
it's not the right thing to do the
american people
deserve to make the decision about who
will be the next president of the united
states
and then that person can select who will
serve for a lifetime
on the highest court of our land and so
joe and i are very clear
the american people are voting right now
and it should be their decision
about who will serve on this most
important body
for a lifetime thank you senator
harrison
susan are voting right now they'd like
to know if you and joe biden are going
to
pack the supreme court if you don't get
your way in this nomination
let's talk about that you once again
gave a non-answer joe biden gave it
anonymous trying to answer you
american people deserve a straight
answer and and if you haven't figured it
out yet the straight answer is they are
going to
pack the supreme court if they somehow
win this election
men and women i got to tell you people
across this country if you cherish our
supreme court
if you cherish the separation of powers
you need to reject
the biden harris ticket come november
the 3rd re-elect president donald trump
and we'll stand by that separation
powers in a nine-seat supreme court yeah
let's talk about pac in the court then
let's talk about this yeah i'm about to
so the trump pence administration
has been because i sit on the senate
judiciary committee susan as you
mentioned
and i have witnessed the appointments
for lifetime appointments to the federal
courts district courts courts of appeal
people who are purely ideological people
who have been reviewed by
by legal professional organizations and
found to have been not competent
are substandard and do you know
that of the 50 people who
president trump appointed to the court
of appeals for lifetime appointments
not one is black this is what
they've been doing you want to talk
about packing a court let's have that
discussion
all right thank you thank you senator
let's go on and talk about
the issue of racial justice i just want
the record reflection she never answered
the question
so i remember maybe the next debate joe
biden will answer
the question but i think the american
people know the answer thank you vice
president
in march brionna taylor a 26 year old
emergency room technician in louisville
was shot and killed
after police officers executing a search
warrant in a narcotics investigation
broke into her apartment
the police said they identified
themselves taylor's boyfriend said he
didn't hear them do that
he used a gun registered to him to fire
a shot which wounded an officer
the officers then fired more than 20
rounds into the apartment they say they
were acting
in self-defense none of them have been
indicted
in connection with her death senator
harris
in the case of riona taylor was justice
done
you have two minutes i don't believe so
and i've i've talked with
brianna's mother tamika palmer and her
family
and her family deserves justice she was
a beautiful young woman
she had as her life goal to become a
nurse and she wanted to become an emt to
first learn
what's going on out on the street so she
could then
become a nurse and save lives and her
life was taken
unjustifiably and tragically and
violently
and it just it brings me to
you know the eight minutes and 46
seconds that america
witnessed during which
an american man was tortured
and killed under the knee
of an armed uniformed police officer
and people around our country of
every race of every age of
every gender perfect strangers to each
other
marched shoulder to shoulder arm in arm
fighting for us to finally achieve that
ideal of equal
justice under law and i was a part of
those
peaceful protests and
i believe strongly that first of all we
are never going to
condone violence but we always must
fight
for the values that we hold dear
including the fight to achieve our
ideals
and that's why joe biden and i have said
on this subject
look and i'm a former career prosecutor
i know what i'm talking about
bad cops are bad for good cops we need
reform
of our policing in america and our
criminal justice system which is why
joe and i will immediately ban
chokeholds and carotid holes
george floyd would be alive today if we
did that we will
require a national registry for police
officers who break the law
we will on the issue of criminal justice
reform
get rid of private prisons and cash bail
and we will decriminalize marijuana and
we will
we will expunge the records of those who
have been convicted
of marijuana this is thank you time for
leadership on a
tragic tragic issue senator harrison
black people in america
thank you senator harris vice president
pence let me pose the same question to
you
in the case of briona taylor was justice
done
you have two minutes uninterrupted
well our heart breaks for the loss of
innocent
any innocent american life and the
family of briana taylor has our
sympathies
but i i trust our justice system
a grand jury that refused the evidence
and it really is remarkable that as a
former prosecutor
you would assume that an impaneled grand
jury looking at all the evidence got it
wrong
but you're entitled to your opinion
senator
i think with regard to george floyd
there's no excuse for what happened to
george floyd and justice will be served
but there's also no excuse for the
rioting and looting
that followed i mean it really is
astonishing
flora westbrook is with us here tonight
in salt lake city
just a few weeks ago i stood at what
used to be
her salon was burned to the ground
by rioters and looters and and flora is
still
trying to put her life back together and
i must tell you this
this this presumption
that you hear consistently from joe
biden and kamala harris
that that america is systemically racist
and that as joe biden said that he
believes that law enforcement has an
implicit
bias against minorities
is is a great insult
to the men and women who serve in law
enforcement and i want everyone to know
who puts on the uniform of law
enforcement every day
that president trump and i stand with
you
and it is remarkable that that when
senator tim scott
tried to pass a police reform bill
brought together a group of republicans
and democrats senator harris
you got up and walked out of the room
and then you filibustered senator
tim scott's bill on the senate floor
that would have provided new
accountability new repeat resources
but we don't have to choose between
supporting law enforcement
improving public safety and supporting
our african-american
neighborhoods all of our minorities
under president trump's leadership thank
you very much always stand with law
enforcement and we'll do
what we do thank you your time is the
lives of
african americans thank you very much
record unemployment
record investments in education and the
fight for school
choice for all of our men thank you i'd
like to respond senator harris
i will not sit here and be lectured by
the vice president
on what it means to enforce the laws of
our country i am the only one on this
stage
who has personally prosecuted everything
from child
sexual assault to homicide i'm the only
one on the stage who has prosecuted the
big banks
for taking advantage of america's
homeowners i'm the only one on this
stage
who prosecuted for-profit colleges for
taking advantage of our veterans
and the reality of this is that we are
talking about an election in 27 days
where last week the president of the
united states took a debate stage in
front of 70 million americans
and refused to condemn white
supremacists
and not true it wasn't like he didn't
have a chance
he didn't do it and then he doubled down
and then he said when pressed stand back
stand by and
this is a part of a pattern
of donald trump's you he was
he called mexicans rapists and criminals
he instituted as his first act a muslim
ban
he on the issue of charlottesville where
people were
peacefully protesting the need for
racial justice
where a young woman was killed and on
the other side there were neo-nazis
carrying
tiki torches shouting racial epithets
anti-semitic slurs
and donald trump when asked about it
said
there were fine people on both sides
this is who we have as the president of
the united states and america you
deserve
better joe biden will be a president who
brings our country together senator
harrison and
and recognizes the beauty in our
diversity
and the fact that we all have so much
more in common than what separates us
vice president let me give you a minute
to respond thank you susan i
appreciate that very much you know i
think that's one of the things that
makes people dislike the media so much
in this country susan
is that you selectively edit just like
senator harris did
comments that president trump and i and
others on our side of the aisle
i mean senator harris conveniently
admitted after after the president made
comments about people
on either side of the debate over
monuments
he condemned the kkk neo-nazis and white
supremacists and has done so
repeatedly you're concerned that he
doesn't
condemn neo-nazis president trump has
jewish grandchildren
his daughter and son-in-law are jewish
this is a president who
who respects and cherishes all of the
american people
but you talk about having personally
prosecuted i'm glad you brought up your
record senator thank you
but that's i really need to make this
point when you were when you were d.a
in san francisco when you left office
african-americans were 19 times more
likely to be prosecuted for minor drug
offenses than whites and hispanics
when you were attorney general of
california you increased
the purport the disproportionate
incarceration of
blacks in california you did nothing on
criminal justice reform in california
you didn't lift a finger to pass the
first step back on capitol hill
i mean the reality is your record speaks
for itself
president trump and i have fought for
criminal justice for
thank you vice president fought for
educational choice and opportunities for
african americans
all of our members thank you sir and
we'll do it for four thank you you know
there is no more
important issue than the final issue
that we're going to talk about tonight
and that is the issue
of the election but itself he attacked
my record i would like an opportunity to
respond
let me give you 30 seconds because we
because we're running out of time i
appreciate that
first of all having served as the
attorney general of the state of
california
the work that i did is a model of what
our nation needs to do
and we will be able to do under a joe
biden presidency
our our agenda includes what this
administration has failed to do
it will be about not only instituting a
ban
on chokeholds and carotid holes thank
you not only thank you senator
i would like to go through these are
points that you made earlier in the hour
and i want to talk about the election
itself before we have to but i want to
talk about
the connection between what joe and i
will do in my record
which includes i was the first
statewide officer to institute a
requirement that
my agents would wear body cameras and
keep them on full time we were the first
to initiate a requirement that there
would be a training for law enforcement
on implicit bias because yes
joe biden and i recognize that implicit
bias
does exist mr vice president contrary to
what you may believe
we did the work of instituting reforms
that were about
investing in reentry this is the work
that we have done and the work we will
do going forward and
again i will not be lectured by the vice
president
on our record of what we have done in
terms of law enforcement and keeping our
communities safe
and a commitment to reforming the
criminal justice system of america
thank you senator harris and i'd like to
pose the
first i'd like you to respond first to
the question on our final topic the
election itself
president trump has several times
refused to commit himself to a peaceful
transfer of power after the election
if your ticket wins and president trump
refuses to accept
a peaceful transfer of power what steps
would you and vice president biden then
take what would happen
next you have two minutes so i'll tell
you um
joe and i are i think particularly um
proud of the coalition that we've built
around our campaign
we probably have one of the broadest
coalitions of folks that you've
ever seen in a presidential race of
course we have the support of democrats
but also
independents and republicans in fact
seven
members of president george w bush's
cabinet
are supporting our ticket we have the
support of
of colin powell cindy mccain
john kasich um over 500
uh generals retired generals and and
former national security experts and
advisors are supporting our campaign
and i believe they are doing that
because they know that
joe biden has a deep deep-seated
commitment
to fight for our democracy and to fight
for the integrity
of our democracy and to bring integrity
back to the white house
and so we believe in the american people
we believe in our democracy
and here's what i'd like to say to
everybody vote
please vote vote early come up with a
plan to vote go to iwillvote.com you can
also go to
joebiden.com we have it within our power
in these next 27 days
to make the decision about what will be
the course of our country for the next
four years
and it is within our power and if we use
our vote
and we use our voice we will win
and we will not let anyone subvert our
democracy
with what donald trump has been doing as
he did on the debate stage last week
when again in front of 70 million people
he openly attempted to suppress
the vote joe biden on the other hand on
that same debate stage because clearly
donald trump doesn't think he can run on
a record because it's a failed record
joe biden on that stage said hey just
please vote
so i'll repeat what joe said please vote
thank you
senator vice president pence president
trump has several times refused to
commit himself
to a peaceful transfer of power after
the election
if vice president biden has declared the
winner and president trump refuses to
accept a peaceful transfer of power
what would be your role and
responsibility as vice president what
would you
personally do you have two minutes
well susan first and foremost i think
we're going to win this election
because while joe biden and kamala
harris rattle off a long litany of
the establishment in washington d.c and
establishments joe biden's been a part
of for 47 years
president donald trump has has launched
a movement of everyday americans from
every walk of life
and uh i have every confidence that
those the same americans that delivered
that historic victory in 2016
they see this president's record where
we rebuild our military
we revived our economy through tax cuts
and rolling back regulation
fighting for fair trade unleashing
american energy
we appointed conservatives to our
federal courts at every level
and and we stood with the men and women
of law enforcement every single day and
i think
i think that movement of americans has
only grown stronger in the last four
years
but when you talk about accepting the
outcome of the election
i must tell you senator your party has
spent the last three and a half years
trying to overturn the results of the
last election
it's amazing when joe biden was vice
president of the united states
the fbi actually spied on president
trump and my campaign
i mean there were documents released
this week that the cia actually made a
referral
uh to the fbi documenting that those
allegations were coming from the hillary
clinton campaign and of course
we've all seen the avalanche the what
what you put the country through
for for the better part of three years
until it was found that there was no
obstruction no collusion case closed
and then senator harris you and your
colleagues in the
in the congress trying to impeach the
president of the united states
over a phone call and now hillary
clinton has actually said to joe biden
that under in her words under no
circumstances should he concede the
election
so let me just say i think we're going
to win this election
president trump and i are fighting every
day in courthouses to prevent
joe biden and kamala harris from
changing the rules and creating this
universal mail-in voting that will
create a massive opportunity for voter
fraud
and we have a free and fair election we
know we're going to have confidence in
it
and i believe in all my heart that
president donald trump's going to be
re-elected for four more years
you know i've uh i've asked i've written
all the questions that i've asked
tonight but for the final question of
the debate
i'd like to um write a read a question
that someone else wrote
the utah debate commission asked
students in the state
to write essays about what they would
like to ask you
and i want to close tonight's debate
with the question posed by brooklyn
brown she's an eighth grader
at springville junior high in
springville utah and here's what she
wrote quote
when i watch the news all i see is
arguing between democrats and
republicans when i watch the news
all i see is citizen fighting against
citizen
when i watch the news all i see are two
candidates from opposing parties
trying to tear each other down if our
leaders can't get along
how are the citizens supposed to get
along and then she added
your examples could make all the
difference
to bring us together end quote so to
each of you in turn i'd like you to take
one minute
and respond to brooklyn vice president
pence you have one minute
brooklyn it's a wonderful question and
um
let me just commend you for taking an
interest in in public life
i i started uh following the news when i
was very young
and in america we believe in a free and
open exchange of debate
and we celebrate that and it's how we've
created
literally the freest and most prosperous
nation
in the history of the world i i i would
tell you that
don't assume that what you're seeing on
your local
news networks is synonymous with the
american people
you know i look at the relationship
between justice ruth bader ginsburg the
late justice who we just lost from the
supreme court
and the late justice antonin scalia they
were on
polar opposites on the supreme court of
the united states one
very liberal one very conservative but
what's been learned since her passing
was the two of them
and their families were the very closest
of friends
i mean here in america we can disagree
we can debate vigorously as senator
harris and i have
on this stage tonight but when the
debate is over
we come together as americans and that's
what people do in big cities and small
towns all across this country so
i just want to encourage you brooklyn i
want to tell you that
we're going to work every day to have
government as good as our people and the
american people
each and every day love a good debate
we love a good argument but we always
come together and are
always there for one another thank you
in times of need and we've especially
learned that thank you for the
difficulties of this year
senator harris what would you say to
brooklyn
um first of all i i love hearing from
our young leaders
and when i hear her words when i hear
your words brooklyn
um i know our future is bright because
it is that perspective on who we are and
who we should be
um that is a sign of leadership and is
something we should all aspire to be
um and that you know that brings me to
joe joe biden
one of the reasons that joe decided to
run for president
is after charlottesville which we talked
about earlier
it so troubled him and upset him like it
did all of us
that there was that kind of hate and
division
what propelled joe to run for president
was to see that over the course of the
last four years
what brooklyn described has been
happening joe has a long-standing
reputation of working across the aisle
and working in a bipartisan way and
that's what he's going to do as
president
joe biden has a history of
lifting people up and fighting for their
dignity
you mean you have to know joe's story to
know that joe has known pain
he has known suffering and he has known
love
and so brooklyn when you think about the
future
i do believe the future is bright and it
will be because of your leadership
and it will be because we fight for each
person's voice
through their vote and we get engaged in
this election because
you have the ability through your work
and through
eventually your vote thank you to
determine the future of our country
and what its leadership looks like thank
you
senator harris thank you vice president
pence thank you so much for being with
us tonight
we want to thank also the university of
utah for its hospitality
and most of all our thanks to all the
americans
who watch this debate tonight again our
best wishes for a quick recovery to
president trump
the first lady and everyone who is
battling covet 19.
the second presidential debate is next
week on october 15th
a town hall style debate in miami we
hope you'll join us then
good evening
so
so
you